the prosecution not impressive at all he
he he apparently doesn't even know
anything about the guns and keeps asking
written house where where did you get
this fascination with ar-15s from
you picked it out because it looked cool
i thought it looked cool
that's the reason yes it resembled the
types of weapons that are used in
first-person shooter video games correct
i don't really play first-person shooter
video games i have but i believe there's
a variety of guns including shotguns
pistols
there's guns and video games that
resemble all guns isn't it true when you
would hang out with dominic black you'd
play call of duty and other first-person
shooter video games
sometimes and those are games in which
you use weapons like ar-15s to pretty
much
shoot anybody who comes at you correct
it's a video game where two players are
playing together
i don't really understand the meaning of
your question to be honest isn't one of
the things people do in these video
games try and kill everyone else with
your guns
yeah the video game it's just a video
game it's not real life
isn't it true mr rittenhouse that you
and your friends
used to play cowboys and indians
yeah didn't you mr rittenhouse
i would like to introduce exhibit a a
cap gun
that mr rittenhouse was given for his
10th birthday and when you played
cowboys and indians mr rittenhouse
didn't you point the guns at each other
and go bang bang bang
the prosecution rests its case your
honor this boy played games as a child
russ mike and
and uh isn't it true mr rittenhouse that
a cap gun
like an ar-15 is a
is a type of gun it looks like a gun
yeah that's it that's and that's the by
the way that's the best they had
that's the best case the prosecution
made
as far as i'm concerned all trial
is that kyle rittenhouse
played video games
sometimes i am so happy to bring you an
incredible app right now i don't think
we've ever had a more timely advertiser
get upside
our listeners are making up to 25 cents
for every gallon of gas
every time they fill up just download
the free getupside app in the app store
or google play right now use promo code
knowles kowles get a bonus 25 cents per
gallon on your first fill up that's 50
cents cash back don't pay full price at
the pump anymore get cash back using get
upside down load the app for free
use promo code knowles can wles to get
up to 50 cents per gallon cash back on
your first tank
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred dollars
a month in cash back and there's no
catch it gets added right to your bank
account you can cash out through your
bank account paypal
even an e-gift card to amazon and other
brands download the free get upside app
right now use promo code nols to get up
to 50 cents
per gallon cashback on your first tank
that is code knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s you
can thank me later
this is why it was so impressive that
they brought written house to the stand
they didn't they didn't need to
it was a big gamble
and
i'm i'm beginning to think the reason
they did that is not to gain any
advantage legally i think legally
speaking they had
everything to lose and nothing to gain
but i think this went further than that
i think this was about a kid who was
trying to clear his name who is trying
to focus not just on the court of law
here but the court of public opinion
where the media had just been absolutely
slandering him libeling him smearing him
for months and months and months
and this kid was confident enough and
had the evidence and the truth on his
side that he went up there i'm so glad
you like that clip
i'm really it makes me feel very good
now if you want to get more clips like
that you've got to
ring the bell subscribe you'll get full
episodes of the show and if you want the
fully uncensored show and maybe you get
more notifications than our big tech
friends want to allow head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play
type in the michael knowles show th e
space m-i-c-h-a-e-l space k-w-l-e-s
space s-h-o-w
period
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five-star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you